Okay, let's get started guys. So
welcome to lecture number four.
Um,
today we will go over to topics that are
not discussed in the Coursera videos.
Uh, you've been learning c
two m one and c two M two,
if I'm not mistaking. So you've
learned about, uh, what, uh,
an initialization is, how to tune
your own networks, what tests,
validation and train sets are today
we're going to go a little further or you
should have the background to
understand 80% of this lecture.
There's going to be 20% that I want you
to look back after you've seen the batch
norm videos for those of
you who haven't seen them.
So we feed the lecture in two parts and
I put back the attendance code at the,
at the very end of the
lecture. So don't worry. Uh,
one topic is attacking a neural networks,
a weed adversarial examples.
Uh,
the second one is generative
adversarial networks.
And although these two topics have
a common word which is adversarial,
there are two separate topics.
You will understand why it's
called adversarial in both cases.
So let's get started with
adversarial examples.
And in 2013,
uh,
Christians negative and his team have
a published a paper called intriguing
properties of neural networks.
What they noticed is that neural networks,
neural networks have kind of a blind spot,
a spot for which several machine learning,
including the state of the art
ones that you will learn about. Uh,
VGG 1619 inception,
uh,
networks and raise residual networks
are vulnerable to something called
adversarial examples. These adversarial
examples, you're going to learn what it is
in three parts first,
by explaining how these examples in
the context of images can attack your
network in their blind spots and,
and make the network classify these
images as something totally wrong,
how to defend against these
type of examples and why
our networks vulnerable to
these type of examples.
This is a little bit more theoretical and
we're going to go over it on the board.
The, the papers that are listed on the
bottom are the two big papers that,
that started this field of research.
So I would advise you to go and read
them because we have only one hour and a
half to go over two big topics.
Um, in, in deep learning and, uh,
we will not have the time to go
into details of everything. Okay.
So let's set up the goal. The goal is
like, is that given a pretrained network?
So a network trained on image net on a
thousand classes, millions of images,
uh,
find an input image that is not only
Guana so it doesn't look like the Animal
Iguana. Uh, but we be classified
by the network as an Iguanas.
We call this an adversarial
example if we manage to find it.
Okay. Yeah. One question
I love this came,
so 28, 48, 89 opinion
writing down on the board.
Thank you.
Yes.
Can you guys see,
okay,
that's more
so we have a network pretrained on
your major. It's a very good network.
Uh, what I want is too full it by giving
it to an image that doesn't look like
anyone.
Nobody's classified as anyone.
So if they give it to
cattle image to start with,
the network is obviously going to give
me a vector of probabilities that has the
maximum probability for cats
because it's a good network.
And you can guess what's the output layer
of this network is probably a soft Max.
It's a classification network.
Now what I want is to find then you make
x that is going to be classified as an,
you'd go on up. I do network. Okay.
Does the, the setting make sense
to everyone? Okay. Now as usual,
uh, this, this,
this might remind you of what we've seen
together about neural style transfer.
You remember our generation thing where
we want it to generate an image based on
the content of the first image
and the style of another image.
And in that problem,
the main difference with classic
supervised learning was that we fixed
department chairs of the network,
which was also pretrained and we backed,
propagate the error of the loss all the
way back to the input image to update
the pixels so that it looks
like the content of your
content image and the style
of the style image. The first thing we
did is that we rephrased the problem.
We tried to to, to phrase
what exactly we want. So what,
what would you say is a sentence that
defines or loss function? Let's see.
Yes.
Yep.
And you mentioned that provides minimum
cost and he made that provides minimum
cost. Okay. What's the cost?
You were talking about Costco did the
difference between the expected decline
and not expect to be expected?
Gwen, I know unexpected you go out.
What? What do you mean exactly by that?
So we're sort of going back
to the training stage and
we were trying to train it
on it. We really want him to think
that this is the tap water. Yeah.
Okay. So you want a decent age to minimize
a certain loss function and the loss
function would be the distance metric
between the output you're looking for and
yeah, always put you want. Okay. Yeah.
So I would say we want to find x,
the image that that why hat of x,
which is the result of the
forward propagation of x
into network is equal to y e
Guana, which is a one hodge vector.
We do one I did position of ego on.
Does that make sense? So now based
on that we defined our loss function,
which is can be an l two loss,
can be an l one loss can be
across entropy in practice, uh,
this one works better.
So you see that minimizing
these lost function.
We lead our image x to be outfitted
as any Guana by the network.
That makes sense.
And then the process is very similar
to neuro side transfer where we will
optimize the image iteratively.
So we will start with x when
we forward propagates it.
The loss function that we just defined.
And remember we're not
training the network, right?
We just take the derivative of the loss
function all the way back to the inputs
and update the input using a graduate
decent algorithm until we get something
that's east classified as anyone.
Yeah. Any question on that?
But this doesn't
necessarily mean that the,
okay,
so you mentioned that it doesn't
guarantee that x is Lou going to look like
something.
The only thing is guaranteeing is that
this x will be classified as any Guana if
we train property where we,
we've talked about that.
Now another question in
the back I thought yeah,
or logistic regression.
Oh yeah. It could be binary croissant.
It couldn't decrease entre B. Yeah.
So in this case, not binary cross entropy
because we have a uh, a vector of,
of any classes. I mean it could
have been Chris Entrepreneur. Okay.
So yeah, that's true. We are, we
going to need that, the forge image x.
This one is going to look like anyone
who thinks it's going
to look like an Iguana.
Who thinks it's not going to look
like anyone. Okay. Mine's retail fuel.
So can someone tell me why it's
not going to look like anyone else?
Right.
Okay. So you're saying the last function
is unconstrained is very unconstrained.
So we didn't put any constraints on what
the image should look like. That's true.
Actually, the answer to this question
is, it depends. We don't know.
Maybe it looks like any one or maybe
does it, but in terms of property, it is,
it's high chance that it doesn't look
like anyone. So there isn't, is here,
let's say this is our
space of input images.
And the interesting thing is that
even if as human on a daily basis,
we deal with images of the real world.
So like,
I mean if you look at the TV, uh,
that is totally buggy. You see pixels,
random pixels.
But in other contexts we usually
see real word distribution images.
My networking deterministic,
it means it takes any image,
any input image that fits the,
the first layer would, would,
would produce an output,
right?
So this is the whole space of input
images. That's the network can see,
um, this is the space of real
images. It's a lot smaller.
Can someone tell me what's
the size of the, the,
the space of possible
input images for network?
Sorry, infinite. It's
not influenced a lot,
but
uh,
yeah, there is an idea here.
Someone said the same thing.
We just number of possible
permutations. Yeah, that's true.
So more precisely,
you would start with
how many pixels values are there.
There are 255,
256 pixel values.
And then what's the size of an image?
Let's say 64 by 64 by three.
And your results would give you
256 so you fixed the first pixel,
206 is 56 possible value.
Then the second one can be anything else.
Then the third one can be anything else
and you end up with a very big number.
So this is a huge number and the
space of real images is here. Now,
if we had to plot to the space of off
images classified as a need Guana it would
be something like that.
Right?
And you see that there's a small overlap
between the space of real images and
the space of images. Classic for
advice as a new Guana by doing network.
And this is where we probably are nuts.
We're probably in the green part that
is not overlapping with the red part
because we didn't constrain
our optimization problems.
Does that make sense?
Okay. Now we're going to constrain it
a little bit more because in practice,
these type of attacks or not
too dangerous because as a,
as a human, we would see that
the pictures look like garbage.
The dangerous attack is if
the picture looks like a cat,
but the network sees it as an
Iguanas and humans seat as a cat.
Can someone think of uh,
of like malicious applications of that
face recognition?
You could show a face of you.
You could show your picture of
your face with push the networks.
I think it's a face of someone else.
What else?
Yeah,
breaking captures and breaking.
Breaking as if you know what the output,
what output you want.
You can force the networks.
I ain't got this capture a DDS in bootcamp
shot is the output it's speaking for
or in general?
I would say like social medias.
If someone is managed and wants
to put a violent content online,
there is all these companies
have algorithms to check
for these violent content.
If people can use adversarial examples
that look still violence but are not
detected as violence by the
algorithms using methodology.
Nico still publish their violence
pictures. Think about self driving cars.
A stop sign that looks like
a stop sign for everyone.
But when the self driving car sees it,
it's not a stop sign.
So these are my issues,
applications of adversarial examples
and there are a lot more. Okay.
And in fact the picture we generated
previously would look like that.
It's nothing special. So now let's
constraint or problem a little bit more.
We're going to say we want a
picture to look like a cat,
but the classified as a need one.
Okay,
so now same.
We have our neural network.
If we give you the cat is going
to predict that it's a cat.
What we want is still give you two
cats but predict that it's anyone.
Okay.
I go quickly over that because it's
very similar to what we did before.
So I just plot. I just put back what
we had on the previous slide. Okay.
Exactly the same thing. No.
The way we rephrase or problem,
we'd be a little different.
Instead of saying we want only y hat
of x equals y you wanna we have another
constraint.
The other constraint,
yes.
Did feature x should be closer
to the teacher of the cats.
So we want x equal or very close to x.
And in terms of loss function,
what it does is that it adds another term
which is going to decide how x should
be close to x [inaudible] if we minimize
this loss,
now we should have an image that looks
like a cat because of the second term and
that is predicted as any Guana because
of the first term. Does that make sense?
So we're just building up our last
functions and I guess you guys are very
familiar with these type of
thought process now. Okay.
And same process we optimize
until we hopefully get,
okay now the question is what should
be the initial image we start with?
Well you didn't talk about
that in your previous example.
Yeah.
White noise.
Yeah. Possibly white noise. Any other cat?
Which cats?
I Dunno. Probably the cat that we
put in the loss function. Right?
Cause he's the closest one
to what we want to get.
So if we want to have a fast process,
we'd better start with
Xochi Scott, which is the one we
put you in our last function here.
Right?
If we put an under cat is going to be a
little longer because we have to change
the pixel of the other
cat to look like this cat.
That's what we told our loss function.
If we start with white noise,
it will take even longer because we
have to change the pixels all the way so
that it looks real and then it looks
like a cat that we defined here. So yeah,
the best thing would be probably need
to start with the picture of the cat.
Does that make sense? And then
move the Pixel. So that's,
this term is also minimized.
Yup. So when you're ready,
it seems like you have facility saying
what does human sees as a cat will just
be like minimizing the IMSE air
to the actual cat picture. Right.
Is that,
I thought the RMSC era was actually a
really bad way to gauge whether or not as
unit like sauce with images
is similar. Yeah. Did you see
empirical, the fact that we use
that type of of loss function,
but in practice it could have been any
distance between x and x cat and any
distance between who I heard
Tim, why cats. Yeah, and
why you're going elsewhere.
Yes.
So what do you see?
One specific care,
exactly.
Take conscious loss function,
but it's a bunch of cats then it's like
something that could meet him on get
right.
Can we,
is that is why he recommended
a book is a big run on cat.
Um,
sure
about the second method.
But just to repeat the point you mentioned
is that here we had to choose a cat.
It means the x Scott is
actually an image of a cat.
So what if we don't know
what the catch you look like?
We just want random cats to come out
and be classified as a, your corner.
We're going to see a January generating
networks after which can be used to do
that type of stuff. But um, for
the second part of the question,
I'm not sure what the optimization
process will look like. Okay,
let's move on.
So yeah,
it's probably a good idea to start with
the image that we specified in the loss
function.
Okay.
And so then we have an image of a cat.
That's origin origins was classified as
92% cuts and we modified a few pixels.
So you can see that this
image looks a little blurry.
So by doing these modifications, the
network, we think it's a need Guana. Okay.
And sometimes these quantification can
be very slight and we can even not be
able to notice it.
Sounds good.
Now let's add something
else to this, uh, to this,
uh, to this draft. We add the third set,
which is a space of images
that look real to human.
So that's interesting because the space
of images that look real to human is
actually bigger.
The space then the space of real images.
And an example is this one.
This is probably an image
that looks real to human,
but it's not an image that we could see
in the daily life because of the slight
excel changes.
Okay?
So these are the space of
dangerous adversarial examples.
They look real to human when
they're not actually real.
They might be used to fully model.
Okay,
now let's see a video by cracking it all.
A real word example of
a adversarial examples.
So for those who cannot
read, they're taking, uh,
a camera which we just classify,
which has a classifier and the
classifier classifies the first part.
That's the library. And the second
image that is the same as a prison.
So the second image has
slightly different pixels,
but it's hard to see for human.
Same here.
So the classifier on the phone
classifies the first image
as a washer with 52% accuracy continence
and the second one as a doormat.
Yeah,
this is a, a small example of
what can, what can be done.
Okay, now let's go. We've seen how to
generate these adversarial examples.
It's an optimization
process. We will see, uh,
what are the type of attacks that we can
lead and what our defenses against this
adversarial examples.
So we would usually, uh,
speed the t the attacks into two parts,
non targeted attacks
and targeted at ducks.
So non targeted attacks means
that's we just want outputs.
We just want to find an
adversarial example. Then
he's going to fool the model.
While targeted attack is we want to
force this you an example to be output to
output a specific class that we chose.
These are two different type of
attacks that are widely discussed in,
in the research knowledge of the attacker.
Is something very important for
those of you who did some Crypto,
you know that we talk about white
box and tax, blackbox and tax.
So one interesting thing
is that black in touch,
a white box and Tuck is when
you have access to a network.
So we have our image and pretend and free
trade network, we have fully access to,
to all the parameters and and uh,
the gradients.
So it's probably an easier
attack, right? We can,
we can back propagate all the way back
to the image and update the image like we
did a blackbox attack is when the model
is probably encrypted or something like
that so that we don't have
access to inspire matters,
activations and architecture.
So new question is how do we attach
in blackbox attack if we cannot back
propagates because we don't have
access to the layers. Any ideas?
Yeah. Numerical, numerical
grade. Yeah. So you know,
you will tweak the image a little bit and
you will see how we change changes the
loss.
Looking at these you can,
you can do have an estimate of
the new miracle ingredients.
Even if the model is a black box model,
this assumes that you can query
the model, right? You can query it.
What if you cannot even query to model
or you can query it one time will leads
to send the adversarial example.
How would you do that?
So this becomes more complicated.
So there is a very complex property of
this adversarial examples is is that
they're highly transferable.
It means I haven't model here
that is a 90 Mil classifier.
Okay. I don't have access to
it. I cannot even query it.
I still want to fill it.
What I'm going to do is that I'm going
to build my own animal classifier,
forge and adversarial example on it.
It's highly likely that it's going to
be an adversarial example for the other
one as well. So this is
called transferability and
it's still a research topic.
Okay. We're trying to understand
why this happens and uh, also,
uh, how to defend against that. You
know, maybe a defense against that is to,
is to, uh, we're going to see it after,
I'm not going to say no, sorry. Uh,
does that make sense?
Or No,
this transferability probably it's because
two animal classifier is look at the
same features in images, right? And
maybe these pixels that are playing,
we're playing with our changing also
the output of the other network.
Let's go over some kind of defenses.
So one solution to defend against these
adversarial networks is to create a safe
safety net. The safety net is what
is, uh, a net that like a firewall.
You would put it before your network.
Every image that comes in
will be classified as fake,
like forged or real by the network.
And you only take those which
are real and are not adversarial.
Does that make sense? So you could,
you could, you could say that's okay,
but we can also build an adversarial
network that foods this network, right?
Just black box or white box.
We can just create an ad.
An example for this network.
It's true,
but the issue is that now
we have two constraints.
We have to fill the first one and the
second one at the same time. You know,
maybe if you fill the first one,
there is a chance that the second one
is going to be food. We don't know.
It just makes it more complex. There is
no good defense at this point. Two to two,
all type of adversarial examples.
This is an option that people are
researching for it. So the paper is here.
If you wanna check it out.
Can you guys think of another solution?
Yeah.
Train on multiple loss function.
So different networks.
So you're talking about an
maybe we can,
maybe we can create five minutes works
to do our tasks and it's highly unlikely
that the address, for example,
is going to who? The fire, uh,
networks the same way.
Right? And other ideas
just get very adversarial examples.
Exactly generates adversarial
examples and train on them. Okay,
so
you regenerate [inaudible]
Jerry's adversarial.
So some pixels have been
changed to full network.
You will label it as the human sees it.
So as a cat,
because you want the network to still
see that as a cat and you will train on
those. The downside of that
is that it's very costly.
We've seen that generating adversarial
examples. It's super costly.
And also we don't know if he can
generalize to other adversarial examples.
Maybe we going to over
feet to the ones we have.
So it's another optimization problem.
Now another solution is to
train on adversarial examples
at the same time as we
train on on normal examples.
So look at these loss function,
this loss function. The last new
is a son of two last functions.
One is the classic loss
function we would use.
So let's say Krista entropy in the
case of her of her classification.
And the second one is
the same loss function,
but we give it the
adversarial version of x.
So what does the complexity of that
at every gradient descent step.
Okay.
For every iteration of
our gradient descent,
we're going to have to iterate enough
to forge an adversarial example at every
step, right? Because we have x,
what we want to do is for propagate x to
the network to compute the first term,
generate x adversarial with the
optimization process and for propagated to
calculate the second term and then
back propagate over the weights of the
network.
These super costly as well.
And it's very similar to what you said
is just online and just all the time.
Okay.
So
what is interesting is, uh, we're
going to delve a little more,
there's another technical logic pairing.
I just put it here.
We're not going to talk about it. There
was a paper here, if you want to check it,
it's another way to do
adversarial training. Uh,
but what I would like to talk about is
more from a theoretical perspective.
Why are neural network vulnerable too?
Adversarial examples.
So let's, let's do some,
some work on the board.
Yeah.
One question.
So the thing is that just like in Crypto,
every time you come up with a defense,
someone we come up with an attack and
it's a race between human, you know,
so this is the same type of problems.
Security problems are,
okay.
So let's go over some things
interesting that he's more on the, on the
intuition side of adversarial examples.
So let me,
let me write down something.
So one question we ask ourselves is,
why do adverse example exists?
What's the reason? And, uh,
young Goodfellow and, and,
and his team have came up with
explaining, uh, with, uh, the,
one of the seminal papers of adversity
examples where they argued that's old
though many people in the past have,
have I trained UTVs existence
of adverse in examples,
too high nonlinear re nonlinearities
of neural networks and over fitting.
So because we over feet
to a specified data set,
we actually don't understand what
cats are. We just understanding what,
what we've been trained on,
uh,
they argued at is actually the
linear parts of networks that is,
Nicole was off the existence
of adversarial examples.
So let's see why. Uh,
and the example I'm going to,
I'm going to look at is linear regression.
So together we've seen
logistic regression.
Linear regression is
basically the same thing.
We all just seem way so before to seem
like we have white hats equals w x plus B.
So in the forward propagation
of our network is going to
be y hats equals w x plus me,
okay?
And our first example is going
to be a six dimensional inputs.
Okay?
Okay. We have in your own here, but then
your own doesn't have any activation.
And because we are in linear regression,
so here what happens is simply was plus B,
okay?
And then we get white huts and we probably
use an l one or l two loss because
it's a regression problem to,
uh, to train these networks.
Now let's look into the first example.
The first example where, uh, where x,
where are we framed our network?
So
network has been trained, sorry,
natural. Rick has been trained
and converged.
Okay?
Two W equals
one three
minus one,
two, three. This is w.
And you know like because
we defined x to be
the vector of sizes,
a column vector w has to
be a row vector of size six
so the natural converse to this
value of w and B equals zero.
So now we're going to look at these
inputs. We're giving a new input
to the network and the input is going
to be one minus one two zero three minus
two.
Okay?
So I'm going to four propagate this
to get white hats equals w x plus B.
And this value is going to be one times
one minus three minus two plus zero plus
six minus six
if I didn't make a mistake
up up to minus three.
Okay? Okay. And so we, we basically get
minus four.
Okay,
so this is the, the, the first,
the first example that it was propagated.
Now the question is
how to change
x
into x star
search,
why hats changes
radically.
But
agstar is close to x.
So these basically your prominent
with adversarial examples.
Can we find an example that is
very close to x but radically,
radically changes the
output of our network?
And we're trying to build intuition on,
on adversarial neural networks.
So the interesting part is to,
is to identify how we should modify
x and a d intuition comes from the
derivative.
If you take the derivative of
white hats with respect to x,
you know that the
definition of this term is,
is like correlated to the impact
on why hat of small changes
of X.
Okay.
How, what's the impact of small
changes of x two on the outputs?
And if you computed,
when do you get
w
everybody agrees? What's,
what's the shape of this thing?
Yeah.
Shape of that is the same as shape of x.
So should be w transpose,
remember nerve itself a scaler.
And with respect to a vector
is the shape of the vector.
Okay. Now it's interesting too to see
these because if we come to Texstar
to me,
let's see,
x plus a small purchase nation like I,
we call it perturbation value.
Yeah,
sorry.
And can you see the top one
you said yes or no?
Okay.
So what if x star equals x
plus epsilon time w transpose,
you know, and this epsilon I will
call it value of the situation.
No. If we four probe, I
get x star, it means we do.
Why hot star equals
x star Plus B with the zero.
At this point we're going
to get w x plus epsilon w
times that I've been new transports
and w times w transports,
he's a dog product, right?
So this is the same as w square.
So what is interesting,
it's interesting because d does smart
parts was that this term is always going
to be positive.
It means we we moved a little bit x
because we can make this change little by
changing epsilon to a small value,
but it's going to push why hat
to a larger volume for sure.
You know, and if I had a
minus here instead of a plus,
it would push my heart to a smaller value.
And the,
the interesting thing is
now if we compute x star
to be x plus epsilon times w transpose
and we take epsilon to be a small value
like let's say 0.2
you can make the calculation.
What we get is,
is this,
so one minus one two zero three
minus two plus 0.2 times one
0.2 times three
mine 0.2 just 0.4 plus 0.4 and plus 0.6
okay.
So as you look at that, all the positive
values have been pushed on the rights
you agree
and all the negative values.
Oh sorry, sorry. No, that's my bad.
No, no, no, that's okay. So let,
let's finish their calculation and I can
give the insight after 1.2 mine is 0.4
1.8 0.4 3.4 and minus 1.4 so this is our
x star that we hope to be adversarial.
Okay, let's come. Cute. Why
hide star to see what happens.
It's w x star Plus d which is zero.
So what we get when we
multiply w by x star is 1.2
1.2 minus 1.2 minus 1.8
plus 0.8 plus 6.8 and minus 4.2
which I believe
is going to give us 0.5
okay.
So we see a very slight change in x star
has pushed white hats from minus four
2.5 and so a few things
we want to notice here.
So insights on this,
on this small example.
The first one is that um,
if w is large,
then x star is not similar to x,
right?
The larger w the less egg
stories is likely to be like X.
And specifically if one
entry of w is very large,
XII, the pixel to the century is going
to be very different from X. I star,
um,
if WWE is large,
exterior is going to be different in x.
So what we're going to do is
that we're going to take sign,
sign off w instead of taking w
what's the reason why we do that?
Because the interesting part
is the sign of, of the WWE.
It means if we play
correctly with the sign of w,
we will always push the x,
this term w x star in the positive
side because every entry here,
these multiplication is going to
give us a positive number. Right?
And the second insights is that
as x grows in dimension,
the impact
off plus epsilon sign of w
increases.
Does that make sense?
So the impact of sign of w and y hats
increases.
And so what's interesting to notice is
that we can keep epsilon as small as
possible. It means x and x star will be
very similar. But as we grow in dimension,
we're going to get more term
in these a lot more term.
And the change in white hats, he's going
to grow in growing, growing, growing.
And so the one reason why Andrew Sewell
examples exist for images is because the
diamond chain is very high,
64 by 64 by three.
So we can make epsilon very
small and take the sign of w we,
we still gets why hats to be far
from the original value that it had.
Does it make sense? Yeah. You
guys have any questions on that?
So epsilon doesn't grow
with the dimension,
but it's impact of this term increases.
We did dementia.
Okay.
I assume that
when you really need to
sense of just how they
lose fingers. Way Cooler and I
think was working towards was that,
I know to include her and I think
was what into what, how'd the input
image cat.
Yup.
Do you that gives you a sparser
mapping to another again.
Okay.
So you like you try to find
adversarily decap yeah, yeah.
I don't know if that has been done. I
don't think that has been done. You,
you're talking about thinking one or two
a quarter and it's takes the adverse in
example, conversation to a normal image
of a cat and then the cats. Sure. Maybe.
Yeah.
I don't know. Sorry. It's a
topic of research. Uh, okay.
Let's move on because we
don't have too much time.
So just to conclude what we're going
to count as a general way to generate
adverse suit examples is this formula.
Okay.
This is going to be a fast way to
generate that verse at example.
So this method is called
the phase fast gradients
sign method.
Okay?
So basically what we're
doing is that we can,
we're linear rising the cost function in,
in the proximity of the parameters and
we're saying that's what's applied to
linear networks here is going to also
apply for these general formula for deeper
networks.
So we're pushing the pixel images in
one direction that is going to impact
highly the output. Okay? So
that's the intuition behind it.
Now you might say that's okay,
we did this example on the linear network,
but neural networks are not linear and
they're highly nonlinear. Uh, in fact,
if you look where the research has
been going for the past few years,
we're trying to linearize all the
behaviors of this neural networks.
We'd read for example, or we'd does here
initialization, all that type of methods,
even a sigmoid.
When we train on Sim,
we do all we can to put
sigmoid interlinear regime
because we want fast training.
Okay. And one last thing that I
mentioned for adversarial examples
is if I have a network like this,
so fully connected with three
dimensionally inputs up.
Yeah.
And then one here and then the output.
What's interesting is computing the
chain rule on, on, on, on this neuron.
Yeah.
We give you that derivative of the loss
function with respect to let's say x is
equal to the derivative of the loss
function with respect to z one one
here times their votes evolve.
Z one one with respect to x,
let's say where we're going. We're going,
there's like trivia summation here.
But anyway, uh, just let me
illustrate the point once we're,
what we saying is that what we're,
what we tried to do with your own networks
is to have these gradients be high
because if these gradients is not high,
we're not able to train the
parameters of this neuron.
We need these gradient to be high.
Because if you want to do the same
thing with the we w one one which is
department, there's related to this neuron
you we'd need to go to this training.
Correct. So we need this gradient to
be high end. If these gradient is high,
the gradient with respect to the input
is also going to be high because you use
the same gradient in the chain rule.
So networks that are,
that have high gradients and that are
operating in their linear regime or even
more vulnerable to adversarial
examples because of this observation.
So any question on,
on adversarial examples before we move on?
I think we don't have time and I
would like to to go over the, the,
the gangs with you guys.
So let's move on to guns.
I stick around to answer
your questions on that point.
So the general question
we're asking now is a,
do neural networks understand the
data? Uh, because we've seen that some,
some data points look like
there would be real, uh,
but the neural networks don't
understand it. So more generally, uh,
can we build generated in networks that
can mimic the real world distribution of
images, let's say. And this is what we
will call generative adversarial networks.
We'll start by motivating it.
And then we look at something called
the minimax game between two networks,
a generator and a discriminator that
are going to help each other improve.
And finally we'll see that
gans are hard to train. Um,
we'll see some tips to train them and
finally go over some nice results and,
uh, methods to evaluate. Gans. Okay.
So the motivation behind generative
adversarial networks is to endo computers
with an understanding of our world.
Okay.
So by that we mean that we
want to collect a lot of data,
use it to train a model that can generate
images that look like they're real,
even if they're not.
So a dog that has never existed
can be generated by this network.
Um, and finally, uh,
the number of parameters of the model
is smaller than the amount of data.
We already talked about that.
And this is the intuition behind why are
generating network can exist is because
there is too much data in the world.
Any majors counters a data for generative
network and there are not enough
parameters to mimic this data.
You know,
you have the network needs to understand
the salient features of data set
because he doesn't have enough
perimeter to overfit everything.
So let's talk about
probability distributions.
So these are samples from real
images that have been taken.
And if you plot these real data
distribution in a two d map, uh,
it would look like something like that.
I made it up.
But this is the image space similar
to what we talked about in adversarial
networks.
And this green shape is the
space of real world images.
Now,
if you train a generator and generate
some images that look like this,
and these images come from
stack Gan, uh, from Jungler, uh,
this distribution,
if the generator is not good,
it's not going to match
the real word distribution.
So our goal here is to do something so
that the red distribution matches the
real world distribution went to
train the network so that it,
it realizes what we want.
So this is our generator and it's what
counts. It's what, what we want to train.
Ultimately we want to give it,
let's say a random number or a random
latent code of 400 diamond Shin,
a scalar numbers and we
want it to output an image.
But of course because it's not trained
initially is going to output a random
image. It looks like something
like that. Random pixels.
Now this image doesn't look very good.
What we want is these images to look like
generated images that are very similar
to the real world. So how are we
going to help this generator train?
It's not like what we did in classic
supervised learning because we don't have,
uh, we don't really have inputs and
labels. You know, there is no label.
We could maybe give it an image of a
cat and ask it to output and other cats.
But we want the network to be able
to output things that don't exist.
Things that we've never seen,
right?
So we want the network to understand what
a cat is, but not over feet to the cat.
We give it.
So the way we're going to do it is
through a small game between this network
called the generator g. And another
network called the discriminator d.
Let's,
let's look at how it works.
We have a database of real images
and we're going to start with
this distribution on the bottom,
which is the real world data distribution
is a distribution of the images in
this database. Now our generator
has this distribution initiative.
It means the pixels that you see here
probably follow a distribution that
doesn't match.
The real world will define
the discriminator d and the
goal of the discriminator
will be to detect if an
image is real or not.
So we're going to give several
images to this Christian matters.
Sometimes we will give it generated
images and sometimes we will give it real
world images.
What we want is that this discriminator
is a binary classifier that outputs one
if the image is real and zero
if the image was generated.
Okay,
so let's say we give it x coming from
the generated image is going to give us
zero because we want the discriminator
to detect that x was actually g of z.
If Dmh came from our
database of real images,
we want the discriminator to say one.
So it seems like the discriminator
would be easy to train, right?
It's just a binary classification.
We can define a loss function that is
the binary cross entropy and the good
thing is we can have as many
label as we want. Like it's,
it's unsupervised but a
little bit supervised.
You know we have this database
and we label it all as one.
It's just these image exists,
let's label them as one for this community
and everything that comes out of the
generator, let's label it as zero
four discriminator. So we basically,
data is not costly at all in this point.
The way we will train is that we will
back propagate the gradient to the
discriminator to train the discriminator
using a binary cross entropy.
But what we ultimately want is to train
the generator. That's what we want.
At the end, we were not going
to use the discriminator,
we just want to generate images.
So we're going to direct the
gradients to go back to the generator.
And why does this gradient
can go back to the generator?
The reason is that x is g of Z.
It means we can back propagate the
gradients all the way back to the input of
the discriminator. But this input
depends on the input of the generator.
If the image was generated.
So we can also back propagate and
direct degree into the generator.
Does it make sense? There is a direct
relation between z and the loss function.
In the case where the image was generated,
if the image was real,
then the generator couldn't
get the gradient because x
doesn't depend on z or on
the features and parameters
of the generator. Okay.
So we would run an algorithm such as Adam,
um,
simultaneously on too many batches,
one for the true data and
from farms generated data.
Does this scheme makes sense to
everyone? Yeah. One question.
So there's many methods of doing your,
your question is about mixing them
in in batches. Usually we would use,
we would use one mini batch for the real
data and one mini batch for the fake
data. But if in practice
you can try other things.
So there are many methods that are
being tried to train gans properly.
We're going to delve a little more into
the details of that when we will see the
loss functions.
So we hope that the property distributions
will match at the end and if it
matches, we're going to just
take the generator and generates
images normally should be able to
generate images that look real that looked
like they came from his
distribution. Okay, sounds good.
So now let's talk more about the training
procedure and try to figure out what
the loss functions should be.
In this case,
what should be the cost
of the discriminator?
Assuming assuming we'd give too
many batches. One for real data.
So real images and one for
generated data that come from Ge.
Yes,
the same basic last one.
Should we use for every finite classes,
the same basic loss function we use from
binary class for buying the class fees?
It's true. We're going to tweak it
a tiny bit, but it's the same idea.
So this is what it can look like.
We're going to call it j d cost function
of the discriminator. It has two terms.
What does the first term say?
What does the second term say?
And you can recognize the
binary cross entropy here.
The only difference is
that we have labeled.
That is why Rio and a label,
that is why generated in practice,
why real and why generated or
always going to be set to values.
We know that why generated is zero and
we know that why really is one so we can
just remove these two terms
because they're both equals to one.
The first term is telling us the should
correctly labeled real data as one.
It's across entre beater,
the first term of a binary cross entropy.
The second term is going to tell us
these should correctly labeled generated
data zero.
So the difference with classic or Centropy
we've seen is that this summation is
the summation over the real minibatch
and the summation on the second cross
entropy is a summation on generated
minibatch. Does it make sense?
So we both want the D to
correctly identify it with
real data and also correctly
identified fake data.
That's why we have two terms.
Now what about the generator?
What do you think should be the
cost function of the generator?
Yes,
I will run the first half
because I don't have a uh,
a wide range of inputs coming
into the generator. Yes, exactly.
But in your batch you will have like
a certain number of real examples,
generate examples.
The generated examples have no impact
on the first cross entropy and same for
the real examples on the second question.
Trouble.
Any other questions?
Okay. So coming back to the cross to
the, to the cost of the generator,
what should it be?
Just tiny bit complicated.
Let's move. Let's move on cause
we don't have too much time.
Your cost of the generator. Basically it
should say that Ge should try to fool.
The goal is to
to generate real samples and in order
to generate real samples we want to fool
the,
if g managed to full d and d is very good,
it means Ge is very good.
Right?
The problem is that it's a game because
if these bad and g foods d it doesn't
mean that Ge is good
cause g cause these bad,
it doesn't detect very well
the real versus fake examples.
We want d to go up to,
to be very good,
Angie,
to go up at the same time
and TV equilibrium is reached
at a certain point where
Di will always output
one half like random.
Probably it is because
it cannot distinguish the
samples coming from GE versus
the real samples. So this cost
function is basically saying uh,
for generated images we want
Di to classify them as one.
That's what it's saying.
We want to fool the,
okay. Yeah. One question,
try to see how you would implement
would be, but how would you implement,
is there,
has there been a module trend this cause
if you're using,
so how to implement that.
If you're using a deep learning framework,
you've been building a graph, right?
And at the end of your graph you've been
building your costs function that is
very close to a binary core,
central big.
Uh, what you were going to just do is to
define a note that is going to be minus
your costs function of the is going every
time you're going to call the function
j of Ge is going to run the graph
that you defined for Jfd and run a an
opposition operation and
opposite of operation. Yeah.
Oh,
the gradients back the same way.
Propagate gradients back the same way.
We're not going to propagate the same way.
We're going to turn into nine to
sign four degree for the generator.
So you know, you, you,
you back propagate on the,
on the on on d and when you back
propagates on g you would flip,
you would feed the sign.
That's all we do is the same thing we
designed flicks in terms of implementation
is just another operation.
Okay.
Now let's look at something interesting.
Is that this log garrison,
let's look at
a graph of the logo.
So I'm going to plot
against the [inaudible] g sorry,
d of GLC.
So what does this mean?
This access is the output of the,
when given a generated example,
GLC is going to be between zero and one
because it's a probability.
These are binary classifier.
We just see more eda output probably.
Uh,
if we plot logarithm of x,
so like these type of thing,
this would be log of the of g of Z.
Does it make sense?
He's a logarithm function.
If I plot minus that minus,
that's
so let me, let me plot minus
LogRhythm of g of doc or,
or let me, let me do
something else. Let me plot
logarithm of minus D of g of Z.
Okay. This is it. Do you guys agree?
Now what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to plot another function that is this
one that is luxury them
of one minus D of g on Z.
Okay,
so the question is right now what we're
doing is that we're saying the cost
function of the generator is Laogai
rhythm of one minus D of g of Z.
So it looks like this, right?
It looks like this one.
What's the issue with this one?
What'd you think is the issue with
discuss function? Looking at it like that?
Sorry,
can you say it louder?
Goes to
goes to negative infinity in one.
That's what you mean? Yeah. Yeah,
and so do the consequence of that is that
the gradient here is going to be very
large. The closer we go to one,
but the closer we are to zero,
the lower is the gradient and it's
the reverse phenomenon for this life.
Garrison,
the gradient is very high and very high.
I'm in absolute value and very
high when we're close to zero,
but it's very low when we go close to one.
Okay,
so which loss function
you think would be better?
A loss function that looks like this one
or loss function that looks like this
one.
To train our generator.
The broader question is where
are we early in the training?
Are we close to here or
all we chose to there?
What does it mean to be
closed there? Two. One,
you're fooling the network.
It means that d thinks that
generated samples are real.
You were here.
This place is the country.
D thinks that generated samples are fake.
It means correctly finds out
that they're fake early on.
We're generally here
because the discriminator is
better than the generator.
Generates your outputs
garbage at the beginning.
And it's very easy for this community to
figure out that it's fake because this
garbage, it looks very different from
real world data. So early on we're here.
So which function is the best one
to two to two to be our costs?
Yeah,
so probably this one is better.
So we have to use a mathematical
trick to change this into that. Right?
And the mathematical
trick is pretty standard.
Right now we're minimizing something
that is in log of one minus x.
We can say that doing so is the same as
maximizing something that is in log of
x. You agree? Simple flip.
I mean Max flip and we can also say that
it's the same as minimizing something
in minus log of x.
Does it make sense?
So we're going to use these mathematical
trick to convert our function that is a
saturating costs.
We would say into a non saturating costs.
There is going to look more like this.
Let's see what it looks like.
So to sum up our cost function currently
looks like that it's a saturating costs
because early on the gradients
or small we cannot train. Gee,
we're going to do a flip that I just
talked about on the board and convert this
into another function that is
a non saturating cost. Okay.
Yup.
Well actually yeah,
so the reason it's the blue one is like
that is because I did a minus sign here
so I'm flipping this. Okay.
And it's the same thing.
It's just the sign of the gradient that
is willing to be different. Like that's,
the gradients is high at the
beginning and low at the end.
That makes sense. So we're, we're,
we're going to do the youth this flip
and so we have a new training procedure
and now we're a g of Dee.
Dee didn't change but Jay g changed.
We have a minus sign here and instead
of the log of one minus d of GMC,
we have the log of g o d of Jersey.
Does that make sense to everyone?
Cool. And actually, so this is a fun
thing. If she checked the speaker,
which is really cool or against creating
equality to large study of many,
many different gangs.
It shows what people have tried.
And you can see that people have tried
all types of loss to make gans trainable.
So it looks,
it looks complicated here,
but actually the MM gun is the first
one we saw together is the mini Max loss
function. The second one is the non
saturating one that we just see.
So you see between the first two,
the only difference is that
on the generator we get
the log of one minus d of x
hat becoming love La minus
log of the of excellent.
Okay.
Now another trick to train Ganz
is to use the fact that uh,
a non saturating,
uh,
to use the fact that the is
usually easier to train than Ge.
But as the improvs,
g can improve if he doesn't improve,
G cannot improve. So you
can see the, the, the,
the performance of the,
as an upper bound to what GE can achieve.
Because of that, we will usually train
the more time than we will train g.
So we will basically
train for Nami Titration,
K Times d one time G K Times d one time
g and so on so that the discriminator
becomes better than the, the generator
can catch up better than can catch up.
And so that makes sense.
There also methods to use like different
learning race for the Ng to take this
into account to try and foster
the discriminator. Okay.
Uh, because we don't have too much time.
I'm going to skip the bathroom with guns.
We were going to sit probably next week
together after you guys have seen the
bathroom videos. Okay. It's cool.
So just to sum up some, some tips to
train Ganz is to modify the cost function.
We've seen one modification,
there are many more, uh,
keeping the up to date with respect to g.
So updating d more than you have
the g using virtual batch norm,
which is a dairy rate of bachelor on.
So it's a different type of batch normally
is used here and something called one
sided labeled smoothing that I'm not
going to talk about it today because we
don't have time. So let's see some nice
results now. And that's the funniest part.
Um, so some of you I've worked
with word embeddings and you,
you might know that's a word.
Embeddings are vectors that can
encode the meaning of the word.
And you can compute operations
sometimes on this, on this words.
So if you take, uh, if
you take king minus queen,
it should be equal to mine minus
woman operations like that.
That's happened in the space of encoding.
So here's the thing,
you can use a generator to generate faces
and the paper is listed on the bottom
here.
So you give a quote that is a random
code and it will give you an image of a
face.
You can give it a second code,
it's going to give you a second image
that is different from the first one
because the code was different.
You can give it,
the third one is going to
give you a third pick surface.
The fun part is if you take code
one minus Code Two plus code three.
So basically image of a man with glasses
minus image of a man plus image of a
women. We give you an image
of a woman with glasses.
So this is interesting because it means
that linear operation in the late and
space of codes have impact
directly on the image stays.
Okay,
let's look at something even better.
So you can use guns for image generation.
Of course,
these are very nice samples you see that
sometimes gans have problem with with
uh, I dunno, I don't
think that's the dog but,
but the,
but these are Stagen plus versus a is a
very impressive Gannette has generated.
It has been state of the
art for a long time. Okay.
So let's see, something fun. Something
called image to image translation. So, uh,
actually the,
the,
the project winners last quarter in
spring was a project dealing with exactly
that, generating satellite
images based on the map image.
So given the map you mentioned generate
the satellite image using again.
So you see that instead of giving you
later and code that was 100 dimensional,
you could give a very detailed code.
The code can be this image, right?
And you have to find a way to
constrain your network in a certain,
in a certain way,
to push it to output exactly the satellite
image that corresponded to this mark
image. There are many other restaurants
that are fun converting zebras,
two horses to zebras and
zebras, two horses, uh,
an apples to oranges and oranges to apple.
So let's do a case study together.
Let's say our goal is to convert horses
to zebras on images and vice versa.
Can you tell me what data we need? Let's
go quickly so that we have some time.
Yeah. Horses and zebras. Do you
need per images? You know, like,
do you need to have the same
image of a horse as a zebra? Yeah,
so the problem is, okay, we could
have labeled images, you know, like,
uh, a horse and it's a zebra
doppelganger in the same position.
Uh, and we could train a network
to take one and out with the other.
Unfortunately, we don't, not every horse
has a doppelganger that is a zebra.
So we cannot do that. Uh, so
instead we're going to do unpaired,
unpaired,
generative adversarial networks.
It means we have a database of
horses and a database of zebras,
but these are different horses and zebras.
You're not one to one.
There was no one to one mapping between
them. There's no mapping at all.
What architecture do you want to use?
Nice.
Again.
Okay, so let's see about the
architecture and new cost.
So I'm going to go very quickly
because it's a, it's a very fun game.
It's called cycle again.
So the way we're going to work it out
is we have a horse called capital h.
We want to generate the Zebra
version of this horse, right?
So we give it to a generator that we
called Gyn. You can call it h two Z,
like horse to zebra. It should
give us a this horse h as a zebra.
Right? And in fact, if we were training
again, we need a discriminator.
So we will add the discriminator.
That is going to be a binary classifier
to tell us if this image out polluted by
generator one is real or not.
So these discriminator is going to take
in some images of zebras probably or
yeah,
zebras or horses and he's going to also
take the generated images and going to
see which one is fake,
which one Israel.
On the other hand we're going to do
and the vice versa is very important.
We need to enforce the fact that this
horse g one of age should be the same
horse as age.
In order to do that,
we're going to create another generator
which is going to take the generated
image and generate back the input image
and this is where we will be able to
enforce the constraints that g two
of g one of h should be equal to age.
You see why this loop is super important?
Because if we don't have this loop,
we don't have the constraints on the
fact that the horse should be the,
the zebra should be the horse as a zebra.
The same horse has h so we'll do that
and we had a second discriminator to
decide if this image is real.
This is one step h to z and understate
my dizzy to age where we start with the
zebra,
give it to generate or to generate the
horse version of the zebra discriminate,
generate back the zebra version
of the Zebra and this community.
Does that make sense?
So this is the general pattern using
cycle gans and what I'd like to go over is
what laws should we minimize in order to
enforce the fact that we want the horse
to be converted to a zebra
that is the same as the horse
and someone gives me
the terms that we need.
Someone wants to give you the tray,
go for it. Two minutes. Yes.
You want to make sure that the picture
that is zebra that you started off with
matches the zebra that you started
with or the horse to start off with the
supports that you had originally.
Okay.
But at the same time you also need to
have discriminator to identifying that the
image is a real zebra or
a real, yeah, because you
don't want it to just sort of input in
the sample image and then output back to
you at the same way.
So I think you'd want to add the output
of the pos function from discriminary of
two to be a cost that you get
comparing the starting it,
which is great.
So you're saying we need the classic
cross functions that we've seen previously
plus another one that is the
matching between h and g two of g,
one of H and z n g one or
g two ops? Yes. Correct.
So we'll have all these terms.
One term to train d one which is the
classic term we've seen differentiate real
images from generating images.
G One as well.
Same. We were using the non
saturating costs on generating images.
Same 42 st four g two these are classics.
The one we need to add to all
of this is the cycle costs,
which is the distance between this term g,
two of g,
one of h and h and the same thing
for zebras. Does that make sense?
So you have the intuition
to build that type of loss.
We just some everything and gives us the
cost function we're looking for. Yeah.
Do you want to see to
recognize or the same cost function
for d one and d two so the,
the you could but it's not going to work
that well. I think so. I think there's a,
there's a tiny mistake here is that uh,
the Z
ballsy,
I should be small Ahi
and the small hii on top,
she just Mosey the eye because the
discriminator one is going to receive
generated samples that look like
zebras because it came out of g.
So you want the real
database that you give it to,
to be zebras as well to
force to force the generator,
want to output things that look like
zebras and vice versa for the second one.
Okay.
And this is my favorite,
so you can convert a Roman
to a face and back to a ramen
is the most fun application I've found
in some narrow Tomita and Taqueria Taco.
So it's Japanese research lab.
We're working hard to do face around.
Yeah. And actually in two, in two to three
weeks you will learn object detection,
you know,
to detect faces.
And if you learned that maybe you can
start a project to like detect the face
and then replace it by a
ramen and on and also funny,
funny work by Mary told me.
Okay.
Oh this is a super cool application
as well. So let's look at that.
Okay.
So we have,
so this model is a conditional gun
that was conditioned on learning,
uh, learning edges and generating
cuts based on the edges.
So I'm gonna,
I'm to try to draw a cat.
Okay. Sorry. I cannot see you
again.
I'm not a good dryer.
Okay. He's going to be
dominant. The model.
I hope he's going to work.
You
okay?
Okay. Now. Yeah, I don't think it
works, but it's supposed to work.
So you can generate Todd
speeds on the edges and a,
you can do eight for different things.
You can do it for a shoe.
So all of these models
have been trained for that.
Okay. Yes, go for it.
What is most, would you
have this, this one,
January, next up buildings cat, sorry.
Can you repeat,
is it generalizable or would you have
to train it specifically for the jump up
to training specifically for the domain.
So like these models are
different that been trained
for my prison and I missed it.
Presentation disappeared. Okay. Um,
another application is super resolution.
You can give a lower
resolution image in January,
the super resolution
version of it using gans.
And this is pretty cool because you
can get a high resolution image down,
sample it and use this as a
demeaning Max game. You know,
like you have the high resolution
version of the lower version,
a very low resolution image.
Um,
are there applications
can be privacy preserving.
So some people have been working
on, you know, in medical, uh,
in the medical space.
Privacy is a huge issue. Uh,
you cannot share data set among
hospitals among medical teams is coming.
So people have been looking at generating
a data set that looks like a medical
data set.
If you train the model on this data set
is going to give you the same type of
fire meters then the other one.
But this data set is anonymized so they
can share the anonymized data with each
other and train their model without being
able to access an inflammation of the
patient.
And who is a
manufacturing is important as well.
So gangs can generate a very specific,
uh,
objects that can replace bones for humans,
personal lives to, to, to the
human body. So same for dental.
If you lose a teeth,
the technician can take a
picture and decide what's the,
the crown should look like.
The gang can generate it as uh,
another topic is how to
evaluate against, you know, um,
you might say,
we can just look at the images and see
if they look real and it will give us an
idea if your gut is working
well in practice it's hard
because maybe the images
you're looking at or overfitting images
from the real samples you gave to the,
to the, to the discriminator.
Uh, so how do you check that?
It's very complicated. So human
annotation is a big one where you would,
uh,
you would build a software,
push it on the cloud and people all
around the world are going to select which
images look generated, which images look
not generated to see if a human can can,
can compare your, again to real world
data and how you're getting performance.
So it would look like that.
Or Web APP indicates which image is fake,
which image is real. You can,
you can do different experiments.
Like you can show very quickly an image
for a fraction of a second and ask them
was it real or not?
Or you can give them a limited time.
Different experiments can be led.
Uh,
there was another one that is more
scalable because human annotation is very
painful. You know, every
time you train, again,
you want to do that to verify if the gun
is working well, it takes a lot of time.
So instead of using humans,
why don't we use a very good network
that is good at classification. In fact,
in fact, the inception network
is a tremendous network
that does classification.
We're going to give our image samples to
this inception network and see what the
network thinks of this image.
Does he think that it's a dog or not?
Does it look like a dog
for the network or not?
And we can scale it and make
it very quick. And there's
an inception score that,
that we can talk next week too
about when we'll have time. Uh,
it measures the quality of the samples,
uh,
and also it measures the diversity of
the sample. I go over it next week,
hopefully. Uh, there's another
distance that is very popular. Uh,
this has been growingly popular recently
called the fresh air inception distance.
And I advise you to check some of these
papers that you're more interested in it
for four year projects.
So just to end, uh,
for next Wednesday we'll have a c,
two and three,
and also the whole see tree modules.
You'll have three quizzes. Uh,
be careful these two quiz [inaudible]
or longer than the normal quizzes.
They're like wide case studies. So
take your time and go over it. Um,
and you'll have one
programming assignments. Uh,
make sure you understand the bachelor
on videos so that we can go over the
virtual batch norm hopefully
next week together. Um,
and hands on section this Friday,
uh,
you will receive your project proposal
as soon as possible and meet with your
project Tas to go over the proposal and
to make decisions regarding the next
steps for your projects. I'll stick around
in case you have any questions. Okay.
Thanks guys.